herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
lange ist sie angekündigt worden lange
ist sie vorbereitet worden und lange hat
vor allem der Westen auf sie gehofft die
Ukraine gegen Offensive seit etwa zwei
Wochen läuft sie doch wer geglaubt hatte
dass die Ukraine jetzt mit westlichen
Waffen die russischen Truppen einfach
mal aus dem Land fegt die besetzten
Gebiete zurückerobert in wenigen Tagen
der hat sich geirrt die Führung in Kiew
selbst gibt zu die gegen Offensive läuft
langsamer als erwartet warum ist sie ins
Stocken geraten was sind die Gründe was
sind die größten Probleme und wie
reagieren die ukraineischen Streitkräfte
darauf wir fragen und bekommen Antworten
von dem militärischen Experten Oberst
ade Wolfgang Richter und wir werden auch
reden mit unserer Reporterin Alisa
Jungen die in Kiew ist aber auch in der
St auska Stausee war wenn es Fragen
Kommentare Meinungen gibt einfach über
die Kommentarspalten die schreiben oder
an diese E-Mail-Adresse schreiben dann
können wir darüber mit beiden
Gesprächspartnern reden und Antworten
liefern zunächst aber ein Überblick über
die Lage in der Ukraine
Bilder die zeigen sollen die gegen
Offensive geht voran veröffentlicht von
ukrainischer Seite sollen sie die
Zerstörung eines russischen Panzers in
der Region Donez zeigen hier im Osten
des Landes Turm schwere Kämpfe
tatsächlich aber kommt Kiew kaum voran
na der Frontlinie bereiten sich diese
Soldaten auf den nächsten Vorstoß vor
immer unter Beschuss der russischen
Artillerie der Gefechtslärm ist
allgegenwärtig
der Dienst ist konstant stressig im
Großen und Ganzen ist es okay
es geht einfach immer weiter und man
muss auf die Umgebung achten
immer auf die Umgebung achten denn die
Russen hatten genug Zeit sich auf die
gegen Offensive vorzubereiten dass sie
stockt darüber sind sich Experten einig
auch Präsident selenski spricht von
einem vormar der langsamer als erwünscht
läuft offiziell läuft die gegen
Offensive seit zwei Wochen
sie konzentriert sich nicht nur auf den
Osten der Ukraine sondern auch auf den
Süden heftig umkämpft die Region
saporisch ja auch hier trifft die
Ukraine auf erbitterten Widerstand diese
Bilder veröffentlicht vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium sollen Soldaten
im Einsatz zeigen welche Ziele sie hier
angreifen unklar doch dass die Ukraine
nicht wie geplant vorrückt daran kann es
kaum Zweifel geben
reden wir jetzt mit Oberst ad Wolfgang
Richter der uns aus Wien zugeschaltet
ist Herr Oberst vielen Dank dass Sie
erstmal mit dabei sind
schönen guten Abend
was die Offensive stockt die russische
Verteidigung die Gegenwehr ist stark die
russische Verteidigungslinien wohl
schwerer zu überwinden als erwartet
woran liegt das ganze
die großen haben sich sehr gut zur
Verteidigung eingerichtet
tiefgestaffelte Stellungen sie haben
diesen Angriff erwartet sie setzen sehr
viele Minen ein sie setzen jetzt besser
als früher koordinierte Artillerie und
Panzerabwehr ein und so fahren sich die
ukrainischen Attacken fest schon bevor
sie endlich auf die
Hauptverteidigungslinie stoßen es ist
den Russen gelungen dass ukrainische
Adler wie vorher herauszufordern bevor
sie auf die Hauptverteidigungslinie
stoßen das machen sie durch
vorgeschobene Stellung die sie dann
nachdem der Kampf euren beginnt aufgeben
und etwas zurückgreifen das Ergebnis ist
dass die Ukraine dann vorweisen können
dass sie 800 Meter 1000 Meter manchmal
auch eineinhalb km vorgestoßen sind aber
das ist noch kein wirklicher Einbruch in
die Hauptverteilung geschweige denn ein
Durchbruch das hört sich erst zeigen ich
vermute die Ukraine werden jetzt sehen
wo die Schwachstellen der Russen sind
und werden versuchen möglicherweise
etwas umzustellen um
machen mit dem eigentlichen Gegenschlag
der noch kommen kann denn sie haben noch
Reserven dann zu beginnen aber die
Aufgabe ist groß wenn sie wirklich den
Korridor durchtrennen wollen der die
Creme mit den Don Bass verbindet dann
müssen sie ungefähr 80 bis 100 Kilometer
überwinden und dann geht es in Richtung
militopol bertianz
und irgendwo dort konnte der Korridor
durchschnitten werden aber soweit sind
wir noch lange nicht ob ihm das gelingt
das werden die nächsten Wochen zeigen
wir können uns das auch mal ganz kurz
vor Augen halten wir haben hier eine
Karte hier sehen wir sozusagen den Osten
und Südosten der Ukraine und das ist das
was sie meinen wenn wir hier unten eben
die Krim haben geht es darum die Russen
sozusagen hier abzuschneiden hier
durchzustoßen und das rote zeigt eben
die
Verteidigungsanlagen die es zu
überwinden gilt und ja die vielen roten
Punkte zeigen die Russen haben eine
Menge Verteidigungsanlagen ähm
geschaffen ja sie haben es schon gesagt
so viel ist es nicht seitdem die
Offensive begonnen hat haben die Ukraine
nach eigenen Angaben im Südosten acht
Dörfer und 113 Quadratkilometer befreit
das scheint ja wirklich nicht viel zu
sein sie sagen es und im Osten sieht
sogar ganz anders aus der schreibt heute
die Vize Verteidigungsministerin mal ja
die ukrainischen Verteidiger hätten die
Vorstöße des Feindes bei jemand und
Kopierens gestoppt also statt einer u
krainischen Offensive in die Ukraine
davon dass sie quasi eine russische
Offensive gestoppt haben also von einer
ukrainischen Offensive kann man ja gar
nicht da sprechen ist das tatsächlich so
dass sie die Ukraine da ja sogar noch
verteidigen müssen und auch die Russen
wieder versuchen die Initiative zu
gewinnen
ja das ist also ein Kampf um die
Initiative der wird von beiden Seiten
geführt man muss dazu sagen die Ukraine
haben im Gebiet Don jetzt angegriffen
schon vor zwei Wochen sie haben mit
mehreren taktischen Vorstößen versucht
die russischen Kräfte dort zu binden und
haben dann aber den Schwerpunkt
eigentlich nach Süden verlagert nämlich
genau in die Region die Sie gerade
geschildert haben und ich habe vorher
auch darauf hingewiesen habe hier
scheint mir dann doch der Schwerpunkt zu
liegen aber die Ukraine dürfen nicht im
Don Jessica Gebiet aufgeben die Russen
zu binden denn sonst werden Reserven
frei also das ganze hängt natürlich
zusammen dieser Operation aber wie
gesagt ein Durchbruch ist das noch lange
nicht und das wird noch ein sehr harter
und wahrscheinlich auch sehr lustiger
kampft und die Frage ist ob sich diese
Angriffe irgendwann dann doch in diesen
Verteidigungslinien fest beißen mache
und Verlusten und nicht so recht
Vorankommen das wissen wir noch nicht
noch haben die Ukraine Reserven sie
können wenn sie es schaffen die
Schwachstelle zu entdecken
draußen müssen sie viel Raumgewinn
machen dann ergeben sich neue Gefahren
große Flanken Entfernung tun sich aus
auch auf die müssen auch geschützt
werden und hier sieht man mal wieder bei
diesem Beispiel dass es nicht ein
Waffensystem ist dass hier wie oft
gepriesen ein gamechanger ist sondern
das ist darauf ankommt alle diese
verschiedenen Waffensysteme aufeinander
abzustimmen und hier geht es vor allen
Dingen um den Kampf um Ihnen also in den
Räumen zunächst einmal aber wenn man
lange Flanken sichern muss muss man auch
selbst wiederum hinlegen und gegen
andere zu verhindern also diese
Koordinierung ist die eigentliche
Aufgabe und die ist sehr schwer
jetzt hat heute irgendwas
podolniak Berater im Präsidentenbüro
also selenskis Berater getwittert die
bei der Überzeugung der Partner
verlorene Zeit die notwendigen Waffen zu
liefern spiegelt sich im konkreten
Ausbau russischer Befestigungen wieder
die Russen haben sich tief eingegraben
haben die Ukraine recht wenn sie sagen
ja der Westen hat so lange gebraucht die
Waffen zu liefern dass das ja wiederum
den Russen die Zeit gegeben hat sich so
tief in Anführungsstrichen einzugraben
ja das kann man natürlich hinterher
sagen auf der anderen Seite hat der
Westen die Waffen geliefert die die
Ukraine haben wollte sie greifen mit den
mit der strategischen Reserve derzeit an
also mit einer Anzahl von 9 bis 12
Milliarden die mit im Wesentlichen mit
westlichen Militärgerät ausgerüstet sind
und man sieht dass der Angriff dennoch
liegen bleibt es wird immer im Krieg zu
solchen Situationen kommen dass man dann
sagt ja hätten wir dies und jenes früher
gehabt dann hätte man auf der anderen
Seite weniger getan oder tun können um
sich dann zu Verteidigung einzurichten
das war mag ich nicht ganz zu glauben
denn diese Linie die besteht ja jetzt
schon seit fast einem Jahr also da gab
es genügend Zeit für den Russen sich
einzurichten aber das ist wohl auch
geschenkt
wir reden gleich auch noch weiter Herr
Oberst über die westlichen Waffen etc
wir wollen aber jetzt schalten in die
Ukraine
live gehen zu Alisa jung sie ist
derzeitig in Kiew hallo Alisa du warst
aber
vor wenigen Tagen auch noch direkt am
karowka Stausee in nicopol am nördlichen
Ufer jetzt muss man sagen du warst am
einzigen Stausee denn als am 6 juni der
Staudamm explodierte zerstört worden ist
da hat sich unterhalb des Staudamms
dramatisches ähm abgespielt nämlich
heftige Überschwemmungen Überflutungen
weil das Wasser nach Westen nach unten
geströmt ist aber oberhalb des Staudamms
ist es so ganz anderen Dingen gekommen
und das können wir uns jetzt einfach mal
anschauen hier sehen wir auf
Satellitenbilder so war der Stausee
vorher also gigantisch breit kaum zu
überwinden oder nicht zu überwinden und
jetzt ist heute ist das ganze nur noch
ein kleines Rinnsal oder mehrere kleine
Rinnsale hier in nicopol war Alisa jung
und hier sehen wir auch nicht unwichtig
sondern im Gegenteil sehr wichtig dass
der sogenannte Teich mit Kühlwasser für
das Atomkraftwerk favorisier Alisa du
warst da in nicopol du hast den Stausee
gesehen dass alles was sich daraus
ergeben hat wie ist denn eigentlich die
Lage beim Atomkraftwerk saboriert ja
einerseits was Kühlwasser angeht
andererseits ist von ukrainischer Seite
zu hören die Russen hätten
kühlwasserbereiche etc auch vermiet
Nikopol liegt direkt gegenüber vom
Atomkraftwerk saporisa und da konnten
wir uns mit eigenen Augen davon
überzeugen wie viel Wasser da jetzt
fehlt das sind wirklich unglaubliche
Bilder man steht an der anderen
Uferseite man sieht das Atomkraftwerk
und dazwischen wo vorher eine riesiges
Gewässer war ist jetzt wirklich sehr
wenig Wasser man riecht es auch es
riecht dort auch nach fauligen
abgestandenen zu wenig Wasser was da
noch ist das zunächst mal zu der
Situation dort die sich da vorfinden
lässt nach der Zerstörung des Kaufhof
Adams und das in den letzten zwei Wochen
hat das natürlich auch besorgniserregt
der Leiter der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossi ist auch vor
mehreren Tagen zum Atomkraftwerk gereist
um sich selbst ein Bild vor Ort von der
Lage dazu machen denn es wurde sich
natürlich gesorgt darum wie steht es
jetzt um das Kühlwasser was auch
gesunken ist dort in diesem reservoires
der Wasserpegel natürlich auch
zurückgefallen das Reservoir dass man
nutzt um dort eben die das AKW zu kühlen
mit Pumpen zu kühlen wenn der Pegel zu
niedrig ist funktionieren diese Pumpen
nicht groß sie war da hatte für dieses
Problem für den Moment Entwarnung
gegeben gesagt man sei da also für die
nächsten Wochen auf jeden Fall
vorbereitet mit alternativen Lösungen
aber jetzt hatte sich eben Präsident
selenski gestern noch zu einem weiteren
Problem was Sorge machen könnte geäußert
er hatte gesagt nach ukrainischen
Geheimdienstinformationen hat Russland
also sowohl das Gelände um das
Atomkraftwerk das ist Russisch besetzt
aber eben auch das Kühlbecken vermiet
stark vermiet und er fordert die Welt
auf dort nicht blind zu sein dorthin zu
schauen er hatte gestern Abend in einer
Videobotschaft gesagt er hätte sich mit
Vertreterinnen und Vertretern von G7 und
G20 verständigt sie über seine
Informationen informiert und er forderte
also jetzt die Weltgemeinschaft auf mit
daran zu arbeiten dass dieses
Atomkraftwerk diese gefährliche Lage
dort womöglich vor Ort mit der
russischen Besatzung sofort zu stoppen
sei und was ich daraus jetzt ergibt das
müssen wir in den nächsten Tagen
beobachten
Alisa jetzt bist du in Kiew am Maidan
den wir kennen durch viele Bilder ähm du
warst allerdings in einem Krankenhaus wo
viele verletzte Soldaten sind und hast
gesprochen Eindrücke gesammelt welche
Eindrücke hast du da bekommen
wir waren hier in einem Krankenhaus in
Kiew wo schwer verletzte Soldaten
hinkommen also nach einer Erstversorgung
in der an der Front im Süden und Osten
des Landes wird natürlich zunächst
versucht den Soldaten dort zu helfen vor
Ort aber das ist eben gar nicht so
einfach und das war das was die Ärzte
uns vor allem ganz klar gemacht haben
durch die Offensive gibt es jetzt mehr
Verletzte und vor allem auch mehr
Verletzte mit schwereren Wunden wodurch
werden die ausgelöst durch Minen durch
Schrapnells durch einfach die Angriffe
dort vor Ort an der Front und diese
Soldaten wenn sie dort unten also nicht
mehr gut versorgt werden können müssen
dann schleunigst hier natürlich auch in
dieses spezialisierte Krankenhaus kommen
damit sie dort versorgt werden was haben
wir da also vorgefunden ganz viele
Soldaten mit schlimmen Wunden mit
schlimmen Verletzungen an den Beinen da
geht es dann wirklich darum kann man das
Bein behalten oder auch nicht wir waren
bei einer Operation bei zwei Operation
mit im OP sein bei einer wo eben auch
genau diese kritische Frage gestellt
wurde wird der Soldat sein Bein behalten
können oder nicht nach wie vor ist das
umgekehrt er muss wieder operiert werden
wenn man aber eben auch Soldaten
getroffen junge Soldaten 22 Jahre alt
war einer mit dem ich sprechen konnte
der beide Beine verloren hat bis zum
Oberschenkel unklar ob das mit Prothesen
etwas wird zu laufen und das mit 22 das
sind also schwerste Verletzungen die man
davor findet und eben die Erkenntnis
durch die Ärzte dass das jetzt noch
zugenommen hat in den letzten Wochen mit
auch natürlich jetzt der Intensivierung
der Offensive im Süden und Osten des
Landes
ja jetzt sprichst du noch mal die
Offensive an wir haben es gerade gesagt
die Offensive stockt das ist alles viel
schwerer als vielleicht erwartet es
heißt teilweise aus Kiew ja gut der
hauptschlag kommt noch vielleicht ist
das auch eine Art und Weise zu
entschuldigen oder zu trösten nach dem
Motto die richtige Offensive kommt noch
wir werden Erfolg haben aber wie ist die
Haltung die Stimmung ihr redet ja mit
den Menschen in Kiew auch in anderen
Orten wie ist denn die Einstellung ist
der Glaube da diese Offensive wird
gelingen sind da vielleicht auch Zweifel
was ist wenn diese Offensive nicht
gelingt
wir waren in den letzten zweieinhalb
Wochen insbesondere im Süden also in der
Nähe der Front unterwegs sind jetzt seit
ein paar Tagen in Kiefer mal so auch
direkt mit Menschen vor Ort in Dörfern
20 km entfernt von der Front sprechen
können und hier sind sich alle darüber
im Klaren dass das eben nicht besonders
schnell gehen könnte hier hier sind sich
alle darüber im Klaren dass das
vielleicht sogar sehr lange dauert
Präsident selensky hatte sich auch dazu
geäußert hatte der BBC gesagt man soll
er nicht davon ausgehen dass das hier
ein Hollywoodstreifen sei wo eben mit
einem schnellen Ende zu rechnen sei denn
es gehe ja schließlich um Menschenleben
und das ist auch was wir immer wieder in
Gesprächen mit Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern gehört haben vor allem Ukraine
drinnen wo ja die Männer an der Front
kämpfen insbesondere die Männer an der
Front kämpfen die immer wieder gesagt
haben ja es geht eben genau um unsere
Männer um unsere Väter Söhne Brüder um
unsere Leute und deswegen natürlich
sollte diese Offensive genauso schnell
oder genauso langsam dauern wie sie eben
möglichst wenige Menschen leben kostet
es werden darüber aber auch hier in der
Presse Diskussionen geführt natürlich
was wäre da jetzt der Bessere Weg
schnell oder langsam das weiß natürlich
hier keiner aber was allen am
wichtigsten ist mit möglichst wenig
Verlusten natürlich
ja dann vielen Dank Alisa vielen Dank
für diese Schilderungen und wirklich
doch ja Eindrücke die einem zeigen wie
ernst das ganze ist und das ist eben
nicht wie du gerade gesagt hast einfach
ein Kinofilm ist sondern eben eine sehr
sehr langwierige Sache mit viel Leid und
Schmerz vielen Dank Alisa und du wirst
weiter für uns berichten reden wir auch
über diese Eindrücke jetzt weiter mit
Oberst ARD Richter Alisa hat am Stausee
gestanden der vorher für eine Armee doch
relativ unüberwindbar schien jetzt nur
noch ein Rinnsal ist wir gucken uns das
einfach auch noch mal gemeinsam an ähm
so sah das Ganze vorher aus
hier der Breite Stausee und jetzt Alisa
hat es ja auch noch mal beschrieben sie
war ein nicopol nur noch ein Rinnsal
jetzt könnte man sich ja vorstellen dass
das militärische neue militärische
Möglichkeiten für die Ukraine eröffnet
dass man vielleicht an dieser Stelle
leichter auf die andere Seite vorrücken
kann die Russen vielleicht auf der
südlichen Seite des sagen wir mal
ehemaligen stause ist sich nicht so gut
aufgestellt haben wir können auch noch
mal auf die Karte schauen gemeinsam denn
wenn wir uns das hier einfach mal
anschauen wir haben hier gesehen starke
Verteidigungslinien der Russen das hier
ist der ehemalige Stausee wie er vorher
war der Stau dann hier gebrochen das
Wasser hier weggelaufen wenn wir jetzt
einfach mal hier reinschauen dann sind
natürlich hier in der Tat weniger starke
Verteidigungslinien deshalb die Frage an
sie herobers bietet das die Tatsache
dass dieser stause quasi abgeschlossen
ist neue Möglichkeiten für die für die
ukrainische Streitkräfte
naja zunächst einmal muss man schon
feststellen dass natürlich der Stausee
vorher ein Hindernis war das kaum
überbrückbar war oder überwindbar war
und deswegen haben die Russen sich auch
südlich des stauseese eben nicht so
stark zu Verteidigung eingerichtet wie
sie ja gerade beschrieben haben diese
Lage könnte sich bald ändern aber noch
hat sie sich nicht geändert es ist zwar
richtig zu sagen jetzt ist ja dieser
Pepper dort im Stausee Bett sozusagen
noch eine Rinnsal aber wir müssen schon
auch konzertieren dass das Gelände die
das frühere Ufergelände jetzt also
jahrelang durch einen Stausee durchnässt
natürlich nicht geeignet ist für
gepanzerte Bewegung und das ist ja ein
sehr Sumpf vergessen
lass das Gelände das war im Laufe der
Zeit abtrocknen wird aber soweit ist es
noch nicht das heißt also diese
Möglichkeiten können sich ergeben aber
sie werden sich jetzt nicht kurzfristig
in den nächsten paar Tagen Ergebnisse
sondern wird dann eben warten müssen bis
eine solche Gelegenheit da ist ob das
der Plan der Ukraine ine ist das war mag
ich natürlich von außen nicht zu sagen
aber was wir sagen können ist eröffnet
sich dann in einigen Wochen eher als
Tagen eine neue Option
kommen wir aber noch mal zur Hauptfrage
zurück
Alisa hat es beschrieben sehr sehr viele
Verletzte in den Krankenhäusern durch
die Offensive es wird also wirklich
gekämpft und die Frage ist eben doch
warum hat es bisher keine größeren
Durchbrüche gegeben mit den westlichen
Waffen doch jetzt in der Hand sie haben
es ja selbst gesagt es ist ja eine ganze
Menge geliefert worden und es ist auch
sozusagen das Material an die Front
gebracht worden und steht den Brigaden
zur Verfügung in Ukraine
ja absolut also was wir sehen können ist
dass diese Brigaden mit westlichen Gerät
ausgerüstet sind waren sie eben
Leopard Kampfpanzer Marder Bradley also
die amerikanischen Schützenpanzer auch
einige challenges und das bedeutet dass
jetzt diese strategische Reserve mit
westlichen Gerät tatsächlich zum Einsatz
kommt sie ist auch nicht vollständig im
Einsatz sondern es ist in der Tat
eigentlich das geht am Anfang des
Gefechte um Schwachstellen in der
Verteidigung herauszufinden oder auch in
die Schwachstellen durch Kampf
herbeizuführen um dann dadurch zu
brechen ähm wir müssen noch warten wo
sich die Ukraine am Ende entscheiden
einen hauptschlag wie sie sagen zu
führen der ist noch nicht entschieden
worden jedenfalls nicht nach außen
kommuniziert worden und er insofern
werden diese Gefechte ich glaube nicht
nur Tage anhalten sondern möglicherweise
Wochen wir haben das ja schon
geschildert es geht um einen Kampf in
dem sehr sehr Minen gelegt worden sind
indem man nicht einfach durchfahren kann
das ging ja zu Lasten vor allen Dingen
auch der Soldaten die dort im Einsatz
sind das heißt man muss mühsam und das
unter Feuer Minen räumen da gibt es
sicherlich modernes Gerät dafür aber das
muss alles gut koordiniert werden das
muss unter Feuerschutz passieren die
Arterie muss das entsprechend hinkriegen
und natürlich muss man auch sehen dass
man sich dann schützt gegen die
weitreichenden Waffen russischer
Kampfhubschrauber die mittlerweile dort
vermehrt im Einsatz sind dazu braucht
man wieder die Flugabwehr am Boden also
alle spielt ineinander und es geht noch
einmal darum wer dieses Gefecht besser
koordinieren kann werde Initiative auch
zeigt auch bei den unteren
Führungsebenen der wird am Ende Vorteile
haben aber wir dürfen die Augen nicht
davor verschließen an der Bericht von
Alissa jung war ja völlig richtig das
ist ein sehr sehr verlustreicher Kampf
von da entstehen natürlich ganz
fürchterliche Verletzungen und es ist
schon richtig und das gehört aber auch
zum Standard
das nur eine Erstversorgung hinter der
Front stattfindet und dann die
Verwundeten möglichst rasch im
spezialisierte Zentren nach hinten
gebracht werden um dort wirklich die
entsprechende Versorgung zu bekommen hat
Operation zu bekommen
jetzt einfach noch mal auf die Frage
Thema Minen was sie jetzt angesprochen
haben also es ist ja schön wenn man
einen Leopard 2 Panzer hat wir haben
aber auch Bilder gesehen alles schwer zu
verifizieren aber das eben auch
westliche Panzer von Ukrainern gefahren
worden sind dann auf Minen
wahrscheinlich gelaufen sind und
insofern dann auch ausgefallen sind also
sie machen ja deutlich es ist ja schön
wenn man eine Leopard oder ein
Challenger hat aber wenn es erstmal
darum geht ein Minenfeld zu räumen
bräuchte man vielleicht ein Minenräumen
Panzer Keiler oder eben andere
technische Möglichkeiten erklären Sie
einfach mal wie kann man denn effizient
ein Minenfeld Räumen was die Russen
angelegt haben
naja es gibt natürlich die
traditionellen Methoden die wir seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg kennen dass man mit
sozusagen mit rolltonnen die bevor am
Panzer aufgespannt werden versucht eine
minenschneise zu schlagen das heißt die
die Minen sollen durch den Druck den
diese Tonnen machen
explodieren ohne den Panzer selbst zu
beschädigen wenn man davon einige hat
dann kann man versuchen also eine Gasse
sozusagen durch diese Minenfelder oder
mehrere Gassen zu schlagen aber es gibt
natürlich modernere Geräte man kann auch
Minen sprengschnüre oder Leitern
schießen die dann doch in relativ kurzer
Zeit durch sprengenladung einen großen
streifenfrei kämpfen indem sie eben
diese Minen dort zur Explosion bringen
ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen das ist
natürlich der teilkenntnis die ich nicht
habe ob die Ukraine jetzt diese Waffen
hier im Einsatz haben und wie sie das
machen natürlich auch diese
minenfahrzeuge die dann in den Einsatz
geschickt werden sind ihrerseits ja
wieder Ziele sogar prioritäre Ziele also
kommt es hier wieder darauf an diesen
Einsatz zu decken also zum Beispiel
durch Artilleriefeuer durch niederhalten
der gegnerischen Panzer abwehrt durch
Nebelwände und was man sich alles dort
vorstellen kann das ist eben das gefällt
verbundener Waffen über das wir ja schon
seit einiger Zeit reden das ist Taktik
und das ist nicht getan mit der
Diskussion um einen spezielles
Waffensystem sondern es geht immer darum
den Verbund zu sehen und wer das besser
beherrscht wird hier auch am Ende
natürlich den in Anführungszeichen Sieg
oder jedenfalls das Gefecht siegreicher
werden können als der andere nur müssten
wir jetzt auch konstatieren das Russland
sich nicht mehr so bewegt wie den ersten
Kriegstagen muss dann hat dazu gelernt
die russische Armee ist weitaus besser
aufgestellt sie ist weitaus
koordinierter in dem was sie tun sie
haben wohl den Ernst der Lage erkannt
und haben im Laufe dieses Krieges
dazugelernt dass es übrigens nicht leute
das ist historisch auch nachweisbar
dass sie das immer gemacht haben am
Anfang hohe Verluste in Kauf nehmen muss
man am Ende mit der schieren Wasser aber
auch mit der Lernfähigkeit sich dann
doch am Ende durchgesetzt haben und kann
man natürlich sagen hier muss das nicht
genau so kommen aber wir sollten die
Augen vor den Risiken natürlich auch
gerade eines langjähriges nicht
verschließen
jetzt kommen ganz konkrete Fragen haben
wir eine ganze Menge schon hier noch mal
zu dem Thema Stausee der Stausee der
nicht mehr da ist Roland Karl fragt
welche Folgen hat der ausgetrocknete
Stausee für den Kriegsverlauf wenn die
Böden ausgetrocknet sind
ja wenn die Böden ausgetrocknet sind und
das wird ja noch eine Weile dauern dann
kann natürlich die Geländegängigkeit
dieses
Bodens wiederhergestellt werden und dann
kann man sich auch vorstellen dass man
mit Kettenfahrzeugen oder mechanisierten
Fahrzeugen oder jedenfalls radfahrzeugen
dann über diese
Ufer bzw den Grund des stause ist fahren
kann dann bleibt immer noch mehr in der
Mitte der teilweise ja doch noch
einige ja manchmal nur ein rennsal ist
aber es gibt auch stellen da gibt es
noch 300 m Breite dann muss man gucken
wie tief das ist kann man dadurch warten
oder nicht wie dem auch sei das ist
alles Detail es ergibt sich eine neue
taktische oder sogar operative
Möglichkeit wenn man das Durchfahren
will wenn man genügend Kräfte dafür hat
und das auch koordiniert macht und der
Vorteil den man darin sehen kann ist das
auf der südlichen Seite des früheren
stause ist die russischen Befestigung
eben nicht so vor entwickelt sind und
insofern sich bessere Chancen ergibt
die nächste Frage die
iche oder iche auf Youtube stellt wo
könnten die entscheidenden
Schwachstellen in der russischen
Verteidigung liegen wie gesagt wir haben
hier nochmal die Karte mit den
Verteidigungslinien sowohl im Osten
sehen wir hier die wo hier heftig
gekämpft wird um dann jetzt hier eben im
Süden wo die Ukraine sagen ja es gibt
einige vor Stöße aber wie gesagt diese
ganzen Verteidigungslinien sind sehr
heftig nun ist die Frage wo könnte denn
die größte Schwachstelle liegen haben
sie da ein Riecher eine Ahnung oder
sagen Sie na ja das haben die Ukraine
mir noch nicht gesagt wenn sie jetzt
gerade ja testen sozusagen die
Frontlinie der Russen auf ihre
Schwachstellen
ganz offen sein erstens sollten wir
nicht versuchen von der Seitenlinie oder
vom Küchentisch her jetzt das zu tun was
wir während einer
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft getan haben
oder während der corona-krise dann waren
alle Virologen oder alle Bundestrainer
und das kann man natürlich nicht tun
selbst wenn ich es wüsste ich würde es
wahrscheinlich öffentlich jetzt nicht
sagen aber das ist letztlich Sache der
Ukrainer das herauszufinden und dann
dort einen äh ein Schwerpunkt das ist
völlig klar ich glaube solche
Detailfragen würden dann soweit gehen am
Ende kommt es aber auf ein paar
Grundsätze an die wir schon öfters
besprochen haben nämlich die Initiative
die auch auf den unterführungsebenen
entwickelt sein muss damit man Erfolg
hat werden nur auf zentrale
führungsentscheidung schaut wird immer
zu spät kommen das ist eine ein Grund
übel sozusagen in der russischen
führungsstheorie dass man vieles geheim
hält nur auf oberen Ebenen entscheidet
und wenn die Entscheidung mal
runterkommen müssen die Gelegenheiten
vorbei
die Bundeswehr ist völlig anders
ausgebildet sie setzt auf das führende
Auftrag das heißt jeder sollte wenn es
gut läuft seine Gelegenheit erkennen im
Rahmen seines Auftrags und dann sofort
handeln und das nennt man dann eben die
Initiative auch auf den unteren
Führungsebene ob die Ukraine dann auf
der operativen Führungsebene die
Initiative ergreifen können wird sich
dann zeigen wenn man Schwachstellen
gefunden hat und wenn man diese
Schwachstellen durchstoßen hat dann
kommen neue Aufgaben dann muss man
Kräfte sehr schnell heranführen sie
gegen Luftangriffe schützen wir den
entsprechenden Mitteln sie auch gegen
Flanken Angriffe schützen dann muss man
selber vielleicht nie erlegen in der
Flanke um nicht dann wieder eingedrückt
zu werden und man muss das Ganze vor
allen Dingen logistischen Griff haben
man muss es also auch versorgen können
über lange Linien und ich weiß noch mal
darauf hin dass die vermutlichen
Angriffsziele ja immer noch 80 bis 100
km weit südlich liegen und das ist
natürlich keine Aufgabe aber die wird
sich erst dann stellen wenn man die
Hauptverteidigungslinie durchstoßen kann
aber auch gerade angesprochen die
Versorgung die ja auch gewährleistet
sein muss eben auch einer der vielen
Mosaiksteine die bei einer Offensive
ganz entscheidend und wichtig ist wie
ist denn zur Zeit die logistische Lage
der Ukraine im Hinblick auf die
Versorgung ihrer gegen Offensive ist
eine Frage
also ich gehe mal davon aus dass durch
die Initiativen die gerade auch diese
munitionslieferungen aus dem Westen
gebracht haben nun zumindest für die
erste Phase der gegen Offensive doch
eine große Menge an
notwendiger Munition vorhanden ist wir
sprechen jetzt über westliche
Waffensysteme also über Geschütze mit
einem Standardkaliber der NATO von 155
mm etc darüber hinaus ist natürlich auch
noch ukrainisches Gerät im Einsatz also
sprich schweizerisches Gerät und
Nachfolgemodelle wir sollten nicht
vergessen die Ukraine waren immer ein
sehr Rüstung starkes Land sie haben ein
Drittel der Rüstungsindustrie der
Sowjetunion damals getragen und haben ja
viele Dinge auch nach dem Zusammenbruch
der Sowjetunion weiterentwickelt sie das
sehe die luftverteidigungssysteme ist
300 und Varianten die sie gut
weiterentwickelt haben mit denen sie
auch erfolgreich haben natürlich kommen
jetzt westliches Systeme dazu das anders
wenn aber kombiniert werden im Grunde
genommen ist es für ein Logistiker ein
halber Albtraum wenn man sieht wie viele
unterschiedliche Systeme im Einsatz sind
die alle versorgt werden müssen und wo
man die versorgungsströme auch richtig
lenken muss damit sie an die Stelle
kommen wo die entsprechenden Systeme
sind und das sind manchmal auch nur ein
paar Dutzend und das ist natürlich keine
leichte Aufgabe gleichwohl gehe ich
davon aus dass für diese gegen Offensive
die Logistik zunächst einmal gesichert
ist ob das in mehreren Wochen oder gar
Monaten noch der Fall ist es eine völlig
andere Frage dann wird man abhängig sein
von Nachlieferungen auf aus dem Essen
[Musik]
jetzt ganz aktuell ist zu lesen
pregorian der Chef der Wagner Söldner
sagt auf Online-Netzwerken die
Streitkräfte der Ukraine drängen die
russische Armee zurück er spricht also
von Erfolgen auf dem Schlachtfeld zieht
sich die russische Armee an den Fronten
von saborischer und Herren zurück
drastische Worte also gleichzeitig auch
drastische Worte an die Heimatfront in
Anführungsstrichen er fragt weshalb hat
die militärische spezialoperation
angefangen der Krieg wurde für die
Selbstdarstellung eines Haufen Bastarde
gebraucht also krasse deutliche Worte
von prigowin jetzt fragt Jonas weiß über
Youtube sind diese Aussagen von
pregorian ebenfalls unter diesem Aspekt
Irreführung zu bewerten deuten sie
wirklich auf Missstände hin also auf
wirkliche Erfolge der Ukraine Missstände
und Fehler bei der russischen Armee oder
sind seine Aussagen so zu bewerten dass
er seinen eigenen Propaganda Krieg
vielleicht gegen ja das russische
Militär gegen den Verteidigungsminister
oder gegen Putin führt
also ich glaube es ist eine Mischung aus
beiden man muss da schon sehen dass er
pregosch in einer ist der immer sehr
starke Worte in den Mund genommen hat
den man aber nicht alles glauben kann
was er sagt er hat also beispielsweise
vor der Eroberung von wachmut mehrfach
angekündigt der würde die Stellung
verlassen und er hat es dann doch nicht
getan sondern dass das war dann ein
geordneter Wechsel zu den
konventionellen Streitkräften Russland
aber er bringt sich natürlich in
Stellung das kann man deutlich sehen der
greift die Militärführung an übrigens
nicht Putin selbst das muss man deutlich
machen
will ja eher als ganz getreuer gut in
jünger erscheinen und glaub die alle
irgendwie nur an der militärischen
Führung ergreift also insbesondere den
verteidigungsmonsterchef der Rassismus
war dass das eine aber er hat natürlich
auch Punkte die durchaus realistische
verständlich ist das was die Russen von
ihrer Armee erwartet haben nicht
eingetroffen übrigens was auch viele
Menschen erwartet haben ist nicht
eingetroffen
sehr viel stärker erwiesen sehr viel
geeinter sehr viel moralisch auch stark
aber auch militärisch gekonnt und das
hat man in Russland nicht erwartet und
insofern gibt er jetzt seinem Unmut
Ausdruck dass das ganze ja schon seit 16
Monaten läuft ohne dass es zu einem
größeren jetzt Erfolg in den letzten
Monaten gekommen ist aber man sollte
nicht vergessen diese Linie die die
Russen erreicht haben die immerhin den
gesamten Süden also zwischen karowska
Stau dann dieper Fluss und
im Westen und in der Person Region und
dann wenn man nach weiter nach Osten
geht die südliche Region und dann eben
auch Mario Paul und einem Großteil der
Dom jetzt gerade das haben sie ja immer
noch im Griff das kontrollieren Sie noch
die Ukraine Rennen
das ist jetzt nicht der ganz große
[Musik]
Armee aber zumindest konnten sie das
bisher kontrollieren und jetzt stellt
sich ja erst die Frage ob eine operative
gegenüber sprechen
die immer
auch immer wieder gemacht hat sondern ob
diese große gegenoperation die ja auch
dazu dienen ein Großteil der territualen
Integrität wiederherzustellen ob sie
dann wirklich Aussicht da verfolgt ich
das wissen wir noch nicht das wird sich
zeigen die Befürchtung ist aber sie wird
sich irgendwann dann doch fest fressen
die Frontlinien werden sich noch mal
verschieben das ist ein operativer
Änderung aber ein strategischer
Durchbruch eine Kriegswende sozusagen
die sehe ich im Moment nicht
das Problem natürlich wenn sich vieles
in die Länge zieht ist natürlich ja ist
das gut für die Ukraine die Russen wir
haben es ja schon gehört haben eben sehr
viel Manpower haben viele Soldaten die
sie wieder immer wieder auf Schlachtfeld
werfen können da ist das nicht so
unendlich bei den Ukrainern wir haben
von Alisa gehört eben viele verletzte
Soldaten eigentlich sind ja fast alle an
der Front und insofern ist die Frage wie
soll das Ganze ausgehen es gibt hier
eine Frage die man sich automatisch
irgendwo auch stellt C&A über Youtube
Herr Richter meine Frage gibt es einen
Punkt an dem man sagen kann dass die
Offensive gescheitert ist oder wo man
sagen kann sie ist gelungen ist das zu
definieren
lassen ich hoffe wir haben noch
Verbindungen
also
ich bin mir nicht sicher unser Bild ist
angefroren ob ich noch zu hören bin ich
hoffe das ist so ich höre sie zumindest
noch die Analyse kommt drüber sehr schön
nein das ist eine politische Definition
ich glaube es war von vornherein
übertrieben zu glauben man könnte jetzt
in einem kurzen kühlen Schwung die
gesamte territuale Integrität der
Ukraine wiederherstellen das glaube ich
ist durchaus schon militärisch vermessen
es hat viele politische Risiken
selbstverständlich auch das betrifft
insbesondere
Operationen und so weiter aber die
Gegner sind die politischen Dingen
man dann verhandeln kann
und wenn er das gelenkt hat
Position dann ist dieser Krieg
enden müssen
also auch wenn wir das Fazit nur noch
bruchstückhaft gehört haben und sie im
kleinen Schwarzen Bild im großen
schwarzen Kasten zu sehen sind seien wir
trotzdem einen riesengroßes Dankeschön
Oberst da D Richter für die Expertise
für die Einschätzung für die Antworten
auf die vielen vielen vielen Fragen hoch
interessant und wir ja sagen sorry für
die vielleicht schlechte Verbindung die
wir am Ende hatten trotzdem sehr sehr
interessant was wir von ihnen erfahren
haben insofern ein großes Dankeschön
vielen Dank und liebe Grüße an sie nach
Wien und sagen natürlich auch noch mal
Danke dass wir Alisa dabei hatten ja das
war unser Livestream zur Offensive was
die Ukraine machen muss die Taktik die
geändert werden muss wie das ganze läuft
und warum das Ganze ins Stocken geraten
ist ich sage vielen vielen Dank für alle
Kommentare Fragen Meinungen und sage
Tschüss bis bald und auf Wiedersehen